voici tout ce qui change à partir du 1er
juillet 2023 les allocations sociales
françaises ne seront plus versées sur
les comptes étrangers hors Union
Européenne seuls les comptes bancaires
établis dans les 34 pays européens de la
zone SEPA pour en recevoir le RSA la
location de solidarité aux personnes
âgées les prestations familiales ou
encore l'allocation supplémentaire
d'invalidité c'est la fin des tarifs
réglementés du gaz si vous faites partie
des 2,6 millions de foyers toujours
abonnés au tarif réglementé d'engie des
comparateurs ont été mis en place pour
vous aider à choisir une offre la
présentation du bulletin de paie va
légèrement changer une nouvelle rubrique
appelée montant net social et créé pour
permettre aux allocataires de connaître
le revenu net à déclarer aux organismes
sociaux le point d'indice dans la
fonction publique et revalorisée de 1,5%
ce qui signifie que le salaire de 5,7
millions de fonctionnaires valent
légèrement augmenter le bonus réparation
est élargi plusieurs aides financières
pour réparer ses appareils électroniques
sont doublés jusqu'à 40 euros pour
réparer une console de jeux vidéo 50
euros pour un téléphone 60 euros pour
une télévision 90 euros pour un
ordinateur ces aides ne sont pas
automatique pour les percevoir il faut
se rendre dans les magasins labellisés
Cali répare